people on both sides of the political
divide feeling tense
anxious and overwhelmed right now but
how do you know when that stress is
becoming a serious mental health issue
in today's health watch denise valdez
shares some startling statistics
well brian a global pandemic is
stressful enough but then you add a
presidential election to the mix
an election that's really divided
families and communities and you can
feel like you're in a real pressure
cooker
so the term election stress disorder is
becoming widely used
widely accepted in fact a recent study
shows just how stressed americans are
feeling
so the american psychological
association conducted the
stress in america study and it shows
that nearly 70 percent of all adults
surveyed
feel the election is a significant
source of stress right now in fact
it found that 76 percent of democrats
and 67 percent of republicans
along with 64 percent of independents
believe this election is a significant
stressor
now stephanie waite is a licensed
therapist in sherman texas
it's a lot to process i think people are
getting it from
not just the media and from television
but from their neighbors and from their
friends and people at the stores it's
just
you almost can't get away everywhere you
that's it and
it's everywhere we turn wherever we go
there's something that's a big deal and
and i'm hearing a lot too we can't you
don't have a lot of control
over these things we don't know the
outcome or when things are going to
be different or what that's going to
look like and so i think that
uncertainty
makes it hard because you don't know how
to plan
you don't know how you know what to
expect and novelty just feels really
uncomfortable
so election stress can translate to
trouble sleeping people being cranky or
irritable
also feeling anxious about being around
folks who might not share your same
political view
so some ways to cope will dr waite
suggest focus on the things that you can
control
you might need to just to give social
media a break maybe even place some
boundaries on what you're going to be
talking about with certain people
be sure to exercise maybe even try some
meditation and if you feel you're really
at a breaking point
talk to someone like a counselor to get
you back in balance